[Music]
I'm dr. John sassa I'm the executive
director of the Vanderpump dog
Foundation and we are here at our brand
new shelter in West Hollywood really the
whole idea of this shelter is to reimage
the shelter and reimage a shelter dog so
we bring in dogs from kill shelters that
don't necessarily look their best they
were neglected they have a lot of
rehabilitation and PTSD issues
immediately when the dogs come in after
they're quarantined and we do our health
assessment we get them bandar Puft and
so that allows them to have a new image
and we've noticed that it really does
improve the way that they walk around
they feel a lot better so now we're
gonna get two of our newest rescues
vanderpoof so let's go meet them my name
is Hannah
I'm the adoption coordinator here at
Vanderpump dogs and this is a Buster
Buster was from a high kill shelter on
his card it said that he was an owner
surrender that means that his owner
didn't want him anymore or couldn't take
care of him anymore if he was not
rescued he probably would have been
euthanized he's pretty dirty but we're
gonna take him and get him all cleaned
up and ready to be adopted this is
someone very special this is Dewey one
of our rescuers who goes to the shelters
for us actually saw Dewey get thrown
from a vehicle Dewey was obviously in a
very neglected situation so his coat is
matted he has fleas and ticks
he's very dirty and he's gonna get a
makeover and surely he's nervous now but
he's gonna get used to his new home and
eventually got a permanent home so let's
go get them vander Puft so typically
when we get these guys in we do a full
assessment on their coats and their ears
and their teeth and just to see what the
condition of the dog is in we give them
a bass and clipping
conditioner and a blow-dry and they look
as good as new right buddy
[Music]
so now that we put on the finishing
touch we're gonna go and make sure that
these guys are spayed and neutered so
that they're ready to go to their
forever home thanks for hanging out with
us today guys
[Music]